-Performing the song,
"Se Te Nota" --
that's my jam --
and making her late-night
TV debut, here is
Lele Pons and Guaynaa.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh-ooh,
ooh-ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Ah, ba-da, ba-da,
ba-da, ba-da, ba-da ♪
♪ Ba-da-da-da ♪
-♪ Ooh ooh ooh ♪
-♪ Si hay rumba,
no quiero más nada ♪
♪ Yo a lo que vine
fue a pasarla bien ♪
♪ Cuál es el plan,
que yo me activo ♪
♪ Dime ¿qué lo que?,
Qué tú quieres conmigo ♪
♪ Te suena el dembow,
bien agresivo ♪
♪ Pero te advierto que dejé
el corazón en la casa ♪
♪ No es la primera
vez que esto me pasa ♪
♪ Tu actitud
la he visto muchas veces ♪
♪ Por más que disimules
ya lo sé, sé, sé ♪
♪ Se te nota
que quieres de mi boca ♪
♪ Cuidao que si te toca ♪
♪ No vas a querer parar,
y-ay, ay ♪
♪ Se te nota
Que estás pasao de copas ♪
♪ Cuidao que te equivocas ♪
-Lele Pons
-♪ Y no te dejo probar,
y-ay, ay ♪
-♪ Lo que tú me digas I'm obi ♪
♪ Pero esta noche
yo no ando lonely ♪
♪ Ando con el mother...Toby ♪
♪ De pasajero
que yo conduzco comiéndome ♪
♪ Un vasito de molusco ♪
♪ Mándame el PIN desde corazón,
que yo lo busco ♪
♪ Se-se le nota,
ma-mamasota ♪
♪ Cómo lo mueve esa muchachota ♪
♪ Menea que se empalaga,
sacude que se empelota ♪
♪ Y es que yo lo sé
Bebé, sé ♪
♪ Se me nota,
que quiero de tu boca ♪
♪ Sé que tú me provocas ♪
♪ Y me pones a temblar
y-ay, ar ♪
♪ Se te nota,
que bailando te alocas ♪
♪ Yo sé que te sofoca ♪
♪ Mi manera de perrear,
y-ay, ar ♪
-♪ Stop, ay,
no te pases de la raya ♪
♪ Tranquilito si no quieres
que me vaya ♪
♪ Te me puedes pegar ♪
♪ Pero te advierto que dejé
el corazón en la casa ♪
♪ No es la primera
vez que esto me pasa ♪
♪ Tu actitud
la he visto muchas veces ♪
♪ Por más que disimules
ya lo se, se, se ♪
♪ Se te nota, q
ue quieres de mi boca ♪
♪ Cuidao que si te toca ♪
♪ No vas a querer parar,
y-ay, ay ♪
-♪ Se te nota,
que bailando te alocas ♪
♪ Yo sé que te sofoca ♪
♪ Mi manera de perrear,
y-ay, ar ♪
♪ Nobeat Music ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Lele Pons ♪
-♪ Y tú ♪
-♪ Mi chichi ♪
♪ El Guaynaabichy ♪
♪♪
-Thanks to
"The Tonight Show."
-Thank you, Jimmy Fallon.
We love you!
[ Cheers and applause ]